we say good morning to Megan Rapinoe
Team USA forward co-captain and
yesterday player of the match two goals
versus Spain and the win next game vs
France this Friday at 3 p.m. Eastern and
Megan joins us now where are you today
Megan we are on the bus heading from
roster Paris you get to have fun today
he's just a day off yeah this is a
little recovery this morning's a little
cool I said all that taking it easy for
the rest of the day now being one of the
veteran players
how does it work for seniority do you
get to sit where you want on the bus
[Music]
like new people coming into the squad I
accidentally said someone else see it
then you gotta tell them women and
they're mortified but I toured the front
I don't want to be getting carsick or be
and seeing trap in the back so I sorts
of proud of us out of the riffraff
you're the younger players make fun of
you to give you grief at all they have a
nickname for you not really I mean I
think as long as I'm keeping up with
them and they don't really have much to
say I like that I like things they're
like what what is what are all the older
players doing we want to do that take us
to the the penalty kick like you know
put us in that moment of are you looking
at the goaltender at all like what's the
process really I don't look at the
goalkeeper too much I mean I kind of
know where it's gonna be in the middle
of the goal I try to just focus on the
process that I go through and the
routine that I have try to stay calm
obviously you're not super calm you know
you're nervous in that moment especially
a moment like yesterday where you know
this could potentially be the winning
goal to put us through the next round
but just trying to pick my spot and you
know put it outside the keepers range I
feel like you know it is so close to
where if you put it in the right spot
the goalkeepers never gonna be able to
get to it
you got scouting reports on all of these
gold tenders yeah we do a little bit but
we've sort of more so focused on just
trying to put it loan in the corners or
high-end in the corners I mean unless
you have like a ginormous goalkeeper in
there that a normal sized one is never
going to be able to reach those corner
so just try to hit it with pace and pick
your spot hit it with confidence
who's putting more pressure on you guys
you guys or the medium us I will say I
think the media puts a lot of pressure
on us but probably nothing compared to
what we want for we're very sort of
critical and analytical about our
performances always wanted to do really
well I mean I would say we no have you
know the expectation on us but I think
that comes from within as well we're
never really satisfied you know really
only for who who once every four years
do we ever get a chance to be actually
really satisfied and that's if we if we
win trophies or not and if we win medals
or not so I think there's no greater
expectation than what we all feel for
each other
what's the biggest difference you think
in being cocky or confidence are
confident when you step on the pitch
probably the level of respect for the
opponent I think teams who are coffee or
players who are concrete yes
don't even really pay attention to to
the opponent and and don't really
respect what they do and think that you
can just go and run all over them I
think we kind of have you know the
highest level of the spec for this home
as availed it seems especially as we
keep advancing are still good they're
here for a reason they put in justice
this is much work as we do and just as
many hours as we do and focus that we do
so trying to break them down realize you
know the strength of their game and try
to combat against that and then
obviously trying to find a little weak
points where we can exploit explain the
quote that you is attributed to you I
hope it's just a total bleep show circus
it's going to be totally awesome I think
this is what everybody wants this is the
upcoming match
with France on Friday so explain the
total bleep show circus there Megan I
just hope this wild I think that this is
you know kind of one of those those
moments in sports where everything comes
together you have considered one of the
heavy favorites against what I consider
a very heavy favor in the host nation
Frances a fantastic side they've had a
good run through the tournament it's
like this is a game everyone that
circles you know all the media wants it
I think both teams are up for all the
fans on it it'll be in Paris it's kind
of this sort of picturesque you know
quarterfinal set they don't get very
often when you have two of the heaviest
hitting teams of the tournament so
hopefully it's wild and the fans are
crazy and everyone's hyped for it
can you trash talk in French yeah a
little bit I can try I only know a few
words I mean give me a little bit give
me a little bit that I might hear on
there cuss words a little bit but I
think I'll just try to give it a look
and try to get them out of the game a
little bit I always like to have a crack
a joke and there's quite a few players I
played with as well in France so kind of
just get them off the game a little bit
when I knew you were going to be on I
still go back to this equality thing I
don't know why this is an issue why why
is this an issue Megan with the women
and the men I I don't understand then
you prove that you are equal or better
yeah yeah I don't understand that would
be a question you could ask our
Federation but well we will be asking it
again obviously very shortly after the
World Cup in no matter what happens but
yeah I mean I think progress takes time
obviously and sometimes people are just
very set in their ways and don't want to
see anything a different way but I think
we're showing that every day we prove it
every day on the field and every time we
step out there not only from just a
performance perspective but also you
know just do
the way that we rally the country and
get behind us the breedings that we have
and the popularity of it is growing it
seems like you know everyday so I think
we got a pretty good case ourselves I've
made it this far and we have any brought
up celebration controversy you're proud
of me house listen they're not doing
I've known her for probably three
quarters of her life I'm friends with
her parents so how she holding up here
she's good she's doing really good we
actually talked about it this morning
yes she's doing very solid back there
for us
I think she's enjoying her first World
Cup experience as a starter good yell at
her tell her mr. Patrick says Lo and
wishes are the best of luck Megan good
luck on Friday and great to talk to you
again great Thank You Man that's Megan
Rapinoe yeah my family is friends with
the goaltender the goalie I'm friends
with her parents
Alyssa Nair and I've known her for a
long time and I forgot when Megan
brought up the fact that she babysat
some of my daughters and that's how long
we've known her yes but those are some
big neighborhood bragging rights how's
your daughter doing
oh she's got you know go to Georgetown
you know how's your daughter oh she just
won the World Cup is coal tender yeah
I'm sorry she's she's on TV right now I
can't talk she's in France yeah 300
million people watching yeah I've known
Megan as well for a long time and you
know when you talk about athletes and
being tough she tough she tough athlete
a great athlete tough athlete not afraid
and you know that those are the kind of
athletes you need on the big stage like
this for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]